من اخر تطورات الانتخابات التركيه حيث
اعلنت هيئه الانتخابات التركيه بانه لا
فائزه في انتخابات امس معلنه الذهاب لجوله
اعاده يوم 28 من مايو الهيئه اضافت بان
اردوغان حصل على تسعه واربعين فاصله واحد
وخمسين في المئه وكليش دار اوغلو على
44.88 كما اعلنت هيئه الانتخابات التركيه
عن فرز 100% من الاصوات وبان نسبه
المشاركين وصلت الى 88.92%
وفي التطورات ايضا اكد المرشح الرئاسي
الحاصل على المركز الثالث في انتخابات
الرئاسه التركيه سنان اوغن انه مستعد
للتفاوض مع اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو لدعم
احدهما في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
وقال ايضا ان مواجهه الارهاب واعاده
اللاجئين اهم نقاط التفاوض مع
اردوغانو واضاف انه مستعد لدعم
اذا امتنع عن تقديم تنازلات للاكراد مشيرا
الى ان مرشحه تحالف المعارضه اوغلو لم
ينجح في اقناع الشعب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وكشفت الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه عن فوز
اردوغان باحدى وخمسين مقاطعه مقابل 30
لمرشح المعارضه كمال اوكلو في تفاصيل ذلك
خسر اردوغان اهم مقاطعتين وهما اسطنبول
وانكر بعد انتصار اوغلو فيهما بفارق ضئيل
كذلك تمكن مرشح المعارضه من السيطره على
جميع المقاطعات شرق تركيا تقريبا وبعض
الولايات في الجنوب الغربي بينما سيطر
اردوغان على مقاطعات الوسط والشمال ابرزها
واكبرها مقاطعه قونيا وكان لافتا ايضا
فوزا في بعض الولايات التي تضررت بنكبه
الزلزال مثلها طاي واضنه بينما فاز
اردوغان في ولايات اخرى متضرره كشارلي
اورفا وغازي عنتاب
اعلن رئيس وهيئه الانتخابات في تركيا احمد
يانر اللجوء الى جوله اعاده لحسم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لاول مره في تاريخ
تركيا وستكون جوله الاعاده المقرره في 28
من مايو بين رجب طيب اردوغان الذي حصل على
49.51% من الاصوات ومرشح المعارضه كمال
كليجدار اوغلو الذي حصل على
44.88 بعد فرز 100% من الصناديق وقال يانر
ان كلا المرشحين يمكنهما البدء بالدعايه
الانتخابيه على الفور وفقا للنتائج
والان مع شبكه مفادي العربيه من اسطنبول
ينضم الينا وفد العربيه طاهر بركه من انكر
فاطمه فهد ومن كهرمان مرعش غسان مرحبا بكم
جميعا معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ابدا
معك فاطمه من انقره اذا الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات اعلنت فرز كل النتائج حتى هذه
اللحظه وبالتالي نسال هنا عن جوله الاعاده
كيف ستكون اليتها من يتنافس ايضا فيها هل
ذات القواعد في الجوله الاولى
تتشابه كليا مع جوله الاعاده فاطمه
[تصفيق]
فاطمه
طيب
يبدو ان زميله فاطمه لا تسمعني سنحاول
العوده اليها مره اخرى حاله تجاوزنا هذا
الخلل الفني اعود الى اسطنبوله الى طاهر
بركه طاهر مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى من جديد
انت موجود منذ الصباح في الشارع بين الناس
ايضا
ما الذي يتحدث به الناس بعد فرز النتائج
بنسبه 100% طاهر عن ماذا يتحدثون عن
الانتخابات عن المرشحين عن البرامج ايضا
كذلك
بل فعل نايف تدور نقاشات كثيره امامنا منذ
الصباح الباكر وطيله ايام وجودنا في تركيا
لتغطيه هذه الانتخابات بين الناس هنا ومن
العادي جدا ان تجد يعني شخصين
يعني يعارضان بعضهما البعض في المواقف
السياسيه يتحدثان قبل قليل شاهدت على
شخصين كان يتحدثان عن الاجور عن موضوع
الاقتصاد وقلنا مرارا انه احد مواضيع
الساعه ويمكن ان نشاهد زحمه الناس من
خلفنا في ميدان الحريه في بكر كوي كان
الاول يقول للثاني ان الحد الادنى للاجور
لا يتناسب مع الايجارات خصوصا في اسطنبول
الايجار هنا 5000 ليره لاستوديو صغير جدا
نايف ما يقارب 250 دولارا امريكيا في
مراتب 8000 ليره نحو 400 دولار فكيف تكفي
لفواتيرنا ومواصلاتنا وطعامنا وشرابنا يرد
عليه الاكبر سنا يقول انت عشت جيلك لم تعش
جيلنا نحن لو عشت جيلنا من فعل شيء لانهم
عاشوا حياه اصعب يقول كنا ناتي بالمياه
بالصهاريج الى منازلنا انظر الى الكافيهات
والى الاسواق والى البنى التحتيه الان
يقصد فتره اردوغان في الحكم فيرد عليه
الاخر يعني لا اجد اناسا لا يجدون وظائف
هنا ندخل في موضوع اللاجئين النقطه
الثانيه التي مرارا ما قلنا انها تؤثر
كثيرا في هذه الانتخابات ما كنا نقوله
كعناوين عريضه ونحاول شرحه هو صلب نقاشات
الاتراك فيما بينهم في المقاهي وفي البيوت
وفي كل المؤسسات هذا عامل مهم جدا بالنسبه
اليهم ودائما ما يتحدثون عنه وبالتالي هذه
محدث محددات اساسيه ستكون بين الاتراك
فيما يتعلق بالجوله الثانيه لانها لم
تتغير ان كان موضوع الاقتصاد لن يتغير في
ليله وضحاها وان كان موضوع اللاجئين اما
المتغيرات الاخرى مثل المواضيع التي يعني
تفرض نفسها على الساحه الان فهي المتعلقه
بالمرشح الثالث وما حصل عليه والى اين
ستتجه اصواته او يعني ايضا من المترددين
بين الرجلين سنعود للحديث عن ما قاله سنان
اوغن معك طاهر لكن نعود مره اخرى الى
انقره الى فاطمه فهد فاطمه كنت اسال عن
اليه اعاده
الانتخابات كيف سيكون شكل هذه الاليه هل
ستقتصر فقط على الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
الحالي ام على
وطبعا مرشح المعارضه كذلك امن كل من تسابق
ودخل في هذه
الانتخابات واتحدث عن سنان اوغن ايضا كذلك
بانه سينضم الى هذه الجوله الثانيه ام لا
في الجوله الثانيه فقط ستكون قصرا على رجب
طيب اردوغان وكليجدار اوغلو لانهم
المرشحين لذا حصل على اعلى ارقام سنان لن
يكون ضمن هذه الجوله الثانيه طبعا الجوله
الثانيه ستكون ايضا مختصره على الرئاسه
فقط لم يكن هناك اي انتخابات نواب او
برلمان البرلمان اصبح من نصيب العداله
والتنميه والاحزاب المواليه لهم بالتالي
اصبحت يعني المعادله اصعب بالنسبه لكدار
اوغلو والمعارضه لانه يعني يرى بعض
المحللون ان اذا كان البرلمان من نصيب
الحزب الحاكم
فاطمه الطيب سنحاول تجاوز هذا
مع زميله فاطمه اتفضل اكمل اعاده الصوره
مره اخرى
ستكون موجوده في الجوله الثانيه سيتم
اعطائهم 72 ساعه تقريبا ليتم الطعن في اي
نتائج انتخابيه وايضا سيحق للمصوتون من
الخارج للتصويت كذلك في الجوله الثانيه
الغسان اغلبيه ساحقه لاردوغان في كهرمان
مرعش لماذا
نايف اكثر من 71% حصل عليها اردوغان في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش ولايه كهرمان مرعش
لطالما كانت تصوت للرئيس اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه في السنوات السابقه وهي
معروفه يعني تميل للرئيس اردوغان وبالتالي
حصل على هذه الاصوات وكان ايضا حزب
العداله والتنميه قد حصل على سته مقاعد من
اصل ثمانيه مقاعد هي نصيب ولايه كهرمان
مرعش في الانتخابات البرلمانيه السابقه
عام 2018 وبالتالي ما زال اردوغان وحزب
التنميه يحافظ على حضوره في هذه الولايه
حتى هذه اللحظه في الامس كان هناك
احتفالات بدات مبكرا بعد يعني بدايه الفرز
بساعه تقريبا واستمرت لساعات الليل
المتاخره حيث انا اقف هنا خلفي هناك مقر
حزب العداله والتنميه هنا تجمهره المئات
ربما الالاف واح لساعات طويله في هذا
الفوز واعتبروه بانه فوز ساحق لهم في هذه
الولايه خصوصا بعد الظروف التي مروا فيها
وبالتالي هم يقولون ان حتى لو الانتخابات
اتجهت الى جوله ثانيه فانهم سيعيدون
الانتخاب او انتخاب الرئيس اردوغان نايف
طاهر يعني الان نحن في طور التجهيز لهذه
الجوله جوله الاعاده بالنسبه لتصريحات
المرشح الثالث
ما الذي تعنيه الان ما الذي تعنيه بالنسبه
الى تحالفه ايضا كذلك استمعت طاهر الى
تصريحاته
ظهر اليوم
طبعا
سنان تصريحاته مهمه ويلعب على الخطين الان
اذا صح التعبير هو يشترط ان يكون هناك
يعني تاكيد على موضوع الحرب على الارهاب
كشرط والشرط الثاني الذي يضعه سنان اوغان
متعلق ايضا باعاده توطين اللاجئين لانه
ينتسب الى قوميين متشددين في فكرهم فيما
يتعلق بوجود اللاجئين الان هذان الشرطان
بحد ذاتهما قد يكونان متناقضين اذا ما اصر
على مكافحه ما يسميه بالارهاب سيكون لديه
مشكله معك كيف يقنع ناخبيه بالتصويت
لكليتش الذي يدعمه اليسار الاخضر حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي اي الاكراد الجناح
السياسي لحزب العمال الكردستاني الذي
يتهمه بالارهاب اما اذا اصر على اعاده
توطين اللاجئين فسيكون لديه مشكله معنا
الرجل الثاني المرشح الثاني الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان الرئيس الحالي لانه يريد ان
يتعامل مع الموضوع برويه ولا يريد اعاده
اللاجئين وخطابها اهدا بكثير في هذا
الموضوع من خطاب كليتش دار اوغلو الذي
يعني تدعمه احزاب تريد اعاده اللاجئين
وربما يرقى البعض ببعض الخطابات المتشدده
الى طرد اللاجئين لانهم يؤثرون على اقتصاد
البلاد بالدرجه الاولى اذا هنا السؤال ما
الذي
يعني يؤثر سنان اوغان ان يكون الاولويه
بالنسبه اليه الحرب على الارهاب
وبالتالي يدعم اردوغان في هذه النقطه ولا
يدعم لانه الاكراد يدعموه او القوى
الكرديه يعني المعنيه بهذا الموضوع بشكل
اساسي او يفضل اعاده توطين اللاجئين
كعنوان عريض وبالتالي يدعم وهنا لا يقتصر
الامر على خياره هو فقط لا ننسى لا ننسى
بان هناك الكثير من الاصوات التي ذهبت وهي
كانت مف اجئه كان نسبه حصل عليها سنان
اوغان ذهبت اليه ليس لشخصه وليس لحزبه
وليس لتحالفه وانما كان هناك هاربون من
التحالفات الاخرى ربما ايضا تتشتت الاصوات
في المره المقبله عندما ناتي الى الجوله
الثانيه في 28 من مايو بانتظار ذلك
فاطمه ماذا عن تصريحات المعارضه بعد هذه
الانتخابات سريعا
حقيقه تصريحات يعني في محاوله لربما يعني
تضمين الشعب وتضمين المناصرين لهم يعني
خرج في تصريح وقال يعني شعبي العزيز نحن
نعمل منذ امس بلا توقف اياكم والياس فانا
لا زلت واقفا منتصبا ساشرح لكم بالتفصيل
اخر المستجدات وبعدها سنقف مجددا وسنفوز
بتلك الانتخابات وفي النهايه سيصير الامر
كما رغب شعبنا اذا هذه محاوله
منكروا في اعمالهم ويستمروا في التصويت
والا يحولوا اصواتهم لصالح الحزب الحاكم
لايف غسان تداعيات الزلزال هل اثرت على
اصوات الناخبين في هذه الانتخابات خصوصا
في كهرمان مرعش وباختصار ايضا
ليس كثيرا نايف لم تؤثر كثيرا لكن هناك مط
الب باعاده الاعمار وتامين المنازل التي
وعد بها الرئيس اردوغان وهناك من حاول ان
يلعب خصوصا المعارضه بهذه الورقه لاحاوله
محاوله خلق الشرع شرخ عفوا داخل صفوف
ولايه كهرمان مرعش من الناخبين المؤيدين
الى اردوغان لكن على ما يبدو ان النتائج
اثرت عكس ذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم شبكه مراسله
العربيه من كرمه مرعش غساله باللوز من
انقره فاطمه فهد ومن اسطنبول طاهر بركه
شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حيث 295 مقعدا عام 2023
تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حيث 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حاز 49 مقعدا
عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد عام
2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44 مقعدا
حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاسس 67 مقعدا
عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات